bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono parigi oggi siano tanti su
happy meals come vedete che tra l'altro
la cosa che rende tutto molto
caratteristico è il fatto che c'è uno
sfondo della mia vecchia camera che mi
sembra di essere tornati ai vecchi tempi
se la realtà non fosse così finta volevo
tornare ragazzi sulla è più visti questo
episodio molto particolare perché ho
deciso di non fare il browser la asus ma
di fare play volevo fare i veicoli più
belli non li farà ovviamente insomma un
miliardo e mezzo però volevo provarne un
po e vedere che cosa succede perché ce
ne sono tantissimi tra i quali ho fatto
anche già balconi of terror che solo
unico messaggero che niente proviamoci
pochettino e iniziamo con l'hotel
persone i livelli più belli in assoluto
di fb più belli non esistono meglio
diversi partiamo
[Musica]
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
come al solito seguito vi è piaciuto
lasciate nascar davanti l'hotel non
penso averlo mai fatto
salve buongiorno bel cappello signora
l'hotel è detto non ho mai capito bene
che che giudica questi livelli con i
migliori sono effettivamente i migliori
cioè si vede che sono fatti da dio sto
uscendo dove vuoi andare al ristorante
al ristorante ok vai nell'assessore ok
in base a quello che schiacciavo
cambiava la cosa figo
ok salve menù del giorno allora zuppa
carne di maiale e banana con ghiaccio
che non ho ben capito il senso buono
stato abbandonato in ghiaccio buongiorno
buonasera a tutti non volevo disturbarvi
però era solo per draghi buona cena e
dall'altro c'e liuc che non so perché
sta tentando di raggiungere la maionese
ma ci penso io sono passato di sopra per
una volta nella vita luke se l'è cavata
con quel nostro tele bellissimo non
volevo dirlo ma è fatto veramente bene
bella sta piscina si fa il bagno il
costume però ragazzi cioè non volevo
dirvelo ma va bene anche così è però
anni vestiti non è proprio il massimo
i ragazzi di arti the fate così fate
bene la rampa direttamente nel deretano
dino nunciato l'hotel signori vero che
ti sia piaciuto mi livello bellissimo
come fa essere dato solo quattro stelle
non lo sono veramente bello è il footer
giocato 31 milioni vivo a me la
classifica allora ero a casa quando sono
al master in un gioco non c'entrava
passata davanti a proprio è un livello
nel senso che poi progredire e vabbé eva
e non pensavo fosse così difficile sei
morto sì però siamo tutti calmi anche
qua vedo che è un po di questa non era
family friendly
ripartiamo salve scherzavo ripartiamo
salve
a passo adesso va meglio sarà toccato
adottata da tappo devo stare vigili
stimo perché mi spuntano dal nulla
van ly vola e superman
mamma mia quanto hollywood in questo
video
clint eastwood mi fa una pifano bunga
ragazzi veramente difficile adesso a
parte gli scherzi
sto livello devi avere una tempo di
reazione che rende anche clint eastwood
con la pistola e renzi ho sete rensi lo
fosse diventato don matteo non ragazzo
impossibile vi giuro io non mi alzo da
questo sgabello finché non ho finito sto
livello ecco allora porca vacca vedi di
morire subito o ci ha messo un ora
occhio che sfrutta qualcuno
all'improvviso dall'albero dall'albero
no c'è una denuncia lo sparatore si farà
ho vinto occhio se non è neanche
scontato capito occhio
no ragazzi incredibile il suo livello no
io finché la guarda ma che voi ragazzi
il discorso che è proprio difficile cioè
nel senso la gente l'hanno messa precisa
nei punti dove non riesci a palla fuori
non ho più la pistola devo vincere con i
carboni piedi sparaco i piedi sparaco i
piedi regalo fai che non esca nessuno
mincio più la mano sola mano perso e ho
perso
ho perso ma non fa niente io vado avanti
e nella vita
mamma mia ragazzi difficilissimo lo
interrompo qua ma vi giuro di ju ve lo
giuro guarda che lo ritroverò e lo
vincerò nel semplice libero giuro devo
riprovarci crimson forest la foresta di
crimson mentale
è una storia che ci siamo spietati con
la macchina dai come hai fatto a entrare
in macchina con la bici trova bene siamo
entrati nella foresta questo qua che
figo beh va beh ma sto male fatto
benissimo
luke e occhio ragazzo io ma tu
avvertirmi ma il figlio inutile del
diavolo non cadere vabbè a doveva cadere
doveva accadere
va bene luke e rimani lì vado in una
scoperta
luke sono morto no non è vero c'è un
ragno che schifo no ragazzi orribile
bene livello più brutto del mondo c'è
più bello in assoluto ma ha fatto fatica
allora yoox è il primo a entrare
stavolta sì pronto vai ecco aiuto sono
stati hai viste potevi passare di sopra
ho lasciato mio figlio con i ragni va
bene ma ora sta andando avanti io non so
neanche dove sarà la prossima entrata e
corpo giorno no non mi seguirà i nomi
seguire nomi seguire chi esce un tizio
notizia ma non mi può raggiungere
prefetto ai miei piedi sono storti ma va
bene non fa niente miu miu che è rimasto
lì il tutto questo
c'è una clavicola che mi sporge dal
collo ma fa niente sembra alla moda come
i referti il giorno radioso
collane crystal lake ho vinto io ho
vinto soprattutto per aver lasciato mio
figlio indietro sono fortissimo livello
stato bravissimo soggetto senza c70
allora io prima fa studio matematica e
poi facci video che ne dite
soggetto 720 9.749 chiuse tipo esserci
figli credo sia tipo sgps cp1 è luke e
ve lo dico io
va beh finalmente ma è un robot lo sai
per quanto tempo aspettato super un
soggetto con senza cervello perché senso
scritti dai box fabriano per l'amore di
dio bianca vai
ecco che vado vado avanti di sopra
eccoci ci sono infiltrati nella che il
figo suo livello
cosa facciamo quelle di questi è diverso
dagli altri
questo perché non c'è agli angoli molto
bene grazie sono fortissimi
quale di questi è il più diverso dagli
altri fuoco sole forno frigo frigo fare
i test salva l'umanità babbo quanto
bello solido che regia occhio di questo
è più diverso uno è tolto l'altro no a
il ragno cascato per terra però a me non
lo posso cliccar e dopo giro
fuggiamo dall'albero dall'albero va ma
ross livello 30 va bene ma so che ha
avuto tutto era mai entrato sono rosti
questi erano i test siano fuggiti dai
test perfetto
mio dio quanto ho fatto bene suo livello
guarda che roba incredibile guarda happy
with che gioca assurde diventato neanche
inside era così bello quale di questi è
più diverso dagli altri che ne so sono
tutti uguali non era questo che non è un
insetto il futuro comincia la terra o
mio dio è cascato un robot ci potremo
dall'altra parte del tuo amico va bene
quindi devo andare avanti di qua
perfetto finalmente un soggetto per i
test non vai da nessuna parte finché non
ti ho testato seguimi nella stanza e
prendi le pillole va bene che è successo
dentro il mio cervello o no kids
disastro solitro la mia testa ma non è
il miglior livello di happy vis mai
fatto nella storia uno più uno uguale 2
un cerchio 11
sì questo sono io e matematica uno più
uno sì
dietro no sono morto porca vacca gli ha
fregato bellissimo nove ragazzi livello
di incredibile questo ipad andy beal
cervelli miracolo poco quello che ti
quello cattivo che io sono rimasto
intrappolato nella mia mente sono morto
mamma mia mamma mia
proverò a fare i good ending che la
prossima volta il livello per ora il
migliore in assoluto miglioria solo
treno fantasma mi ispira proviamo parte
bene orca vacca cori sono dentro ai a
questo è successo che vi sto parlando
c'è un po di frecce conficcate ma non fa
niente immagine eccoci cia no no no no
sto qua e non mi lasciare non mi
lasciare che un casino dai quasi
perfetto mai molto bene ahi ahi ahi ahi
vape allora cosa è successo devo cadere
sulla locomotiva immagine rimanere lì ok
non ho cho perfetto non devo rimanere
sulla locomotiva eccoci sera ma no va
dai beni sono ancora vivono i prodotti
quello è un bel viaggio in treno
frecciarossa prima classe è di cosa ci
lamentiamo
ciao nonno come tutto bene adesso
durando più adesso che prima senza mani
non mi sto leggendo leggendo solo con la
forza della fiducia chiesto uccisio
anch'io sono vivo
death and si voleva e vabbè si moriva
per fortis livello però la bici intatta
la bici a posto
stavo scherzando non fa niente a mia
mamma mi hanno messo un sacco vabbè dai
facciamo mentre ci mette un po a
caricarlo del serbo bello vamos passano
già fatto questo qua perché vi
ricordavate dimension ma non mi ricordo
bene anzi mi dicono niente quindi
facciamo lo sono gli altri che caga a
posto permesso quanto forti venti
mammamia un altro attivista ovviamente
un salve credo che lei sia un nemico non
la tocco devo le miniere profonde va
bene c'è qualcuno che urlava io non li
ho pagati sono andato avanti perché io
sono confidenze come stesso colore
qualcuno sta caricando lo sento oh mio
dio
salta due già fatta sono arrivato a
livello sotto c'era gente oddio
sbagliato dovrà aspettare di più erano
fuori che pirla lo vado era tutto
collegato quindi a un test mansion
international dire comunque casa
infestata è una villa è una casa in sì
però mi sembra più un rustico ma brutto
da sé che usi un accendino di minecraft
iva via fuoco tutto via poco occhio che
c'e un cortina le guarda
non c'è una scala avrei detto il
contrario vedete un boss finale occhio
infatti c'è anche il boss finale vita
[Musica]
mamma mia con te ho rischiato via via è
bravo copriti ed i compiti copre i copri
coop ricopri caricamento per copriva i
suoi se vuoi su bravissimo va bene non
promette bene
mamma mia ragazzi da kirby paone joe
bellissimo ragazzi oggi giocato di più
belli e li vieta in questo penso sia il
miglior episodio di atticus di sempre se
voi andate a scorrere i vecchi questo è
il migliore bisogna che i livelli sono
bellissimi ho giocato roba fighissimo i
ragazzi bravi sia piaciuto come sempre
uno strumento di piacere del tasso
iscriviti e schiacciate la campanella
preso aggiornati sui video riescono e
noi amici miei come sempre ci rivediamo
a un prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]